[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's bring him in Matthew
Berry NBC sports fantasy football
analyst oh we got a drum roll here
Fantasy Life newsletter Matthew Berry
host fantasy football happy hour
weekdays noon Eastern on peacock and
every Sunday he hosts fantasy football
pregame wait can we tell
I told picture day Ray to help Matthew
he didn't know where he was going come
on in my bad Matthew I I'm looking for
better help in the back uh Matt will be
in Kansas City for a football night in
America kicking off the season that'll
be Thursday September 7th ahead of the
Chiefs and lions on NBC in peacock what
do you think of the man cave Matthew
dude this is great I was getting a I was
getting a tour uh before I came on it's
really impressive yeah it's amazing and
I saw some pictures of what it looked
like before you guys moved in yeah it's
unbelievable it's like two different
buildings it was a three-month
turnaround which is that's the other
crazy part to me yes because I mean like
like you guys don't see it on air but
like all the nooks and crannies and like
the lighting up above like it's all
state of the art stuff here yeah like
it's really impressive yeah uh it's it's
the man cave of man caves I'm I listen I
mean I I work in NBC Sports you know
which they have a budget and uh I'm
jealous I'm like I've got one corner of
one Studio I'm very jealous I'm I'm
officially jealous of all this okay
I go back I think the first time I
played fantasy was rotisserie and I
played in 1982 or 83.
and I remember I won my league nice
um I had a lot of Washington Redskins
okay because they you know you had uh
Gary Clark and Ricky Sanders yeah the
Smurfs yeah and um but so that's what 40
years
easy I I'll say this you know I don't
know if I don't know if you know this or
you remember this but uh because I think
I asked permission you're like yeah it's
fine but uh you know I wrote a book a
while ago called Fantasy Life and the
book is it's the story of my life but in
addition throughout woven throat or all
these like crazy stories around the
obsession of fantasy football right and
just the crazy trades people have made
the things they have done the the loser
punishments etc etc and there's a Dan
Patrick story in there about your
obsession around fantasy football it's
the phone booth story yes I had just
gotten my knee cut on yeah and my draft
was at five o'clock and I checked myself
out of the hospital in New York and I
thought I could make it all the way to
Brooklyn in time for my draft well uh so
I literally I took out the IV I I I was
checking myself out and I was drugged up
and this is a while ago so this is
pre-computers pre-cell phones you're not
able to do an app or anything like that
no and then I'm I'm on the subway and
I'm looking at my watch and I realize
I'm not going to make it I get out at
West 4th Street and I come up there's a
phone booth and I did my draft on
crutches on Vicodin and
uh I uh ended up winning winning my
fantasy draft that year that's in that
story you get you hopped up on drugs on
crutches on a pay phone in New York
doing your fantasy draft that is in our
uh our Obsession chapter right there
because I mean that's that just shows
like when you're into it you're into it
okay the best story that you've ever
heard relating to Fantasy uh I mean
there's there's a there's a million of
them I I mean I will say of that I have
a guy this is also in the book uh there
was a guy that uh he was stationed at
the I'm going to mispronounce it so I
apologize the agram air base uh in
Afghanistan I think so he's um again
it's been 12 years since I wrote the
book but so he's State he's he's
stationed overseas like he is he is in
the military he is stationed overseas
and they don't get great internet there
but his draft is coming up and so he
found one place on the on the base uh
outside where he could get Internet so
he's doing his draft and all of a sudden
there's an air raid there are literally
bombs Landing 50 yards from him and they
are like everyone in everyone in and
he's just like I can't I'm in a draft
and they're like dude there's bombs
falling around you and he's like I'm up
into picks
and so you know and I need a flex you
know so um he's just like yeah I know
people think it was crazy but I just I
stayed out there and I finished my draft
he was just like I I always had the
attitude and I was overseas that are
just like when it's my time it's my time
and I'm just gonna uh you know I'm Gonna
Roll the Dice and he stayed out there
stayed through a bomb shower uh on on a
base and obviously live to tell about it
so it's amazing story that's the
craziest one I think I've heard the uh
best punishment for somebody finishing
last in fantasy
yeah I mean there's uh Define best I
guess I've heard some I've heard a
bunches yeah I mean like it so like I've
heard some great ones right I mean
there's you know everyone's heard about
the tattoo League where the losers of
the league gets a tattoo a permanent
tattoo chosen by the winner like there
is a guy walking around Omaha Nebraska
with a tattoo of Justin Bieber's face
that says hashtag yellow swag right
there's uh there's another guy in that
same league that has a picture of me
like that's even worse right that's even
like wait what's that
um yeah because I featured them in the
book and so that year the loser League
uh the winner chose a tattoo of me which
I think is even much worse than Justin
Bieber uh I mean I've heard of one of my
favorite ones and I because I know
you're uh you're a basketball player you
know and we were shooting little Hoops
before the before the show this one's
pretty good is you know how like in
grade school they have those eight foot
hoops
so this one the loser League had to go
and stand under the hoop where everyone
else in the league posterized them and
they shot it in slow motion and like
their things there's a video on on
YouTube
um so they all just dunked on him I
think that's pretty good uh I've there's
a league in Brooklyn New York where the
loser of the league has to dress as a
lion
and the rest of the league chases him
with a paintball gun and just hunts him
down
I think is uh that one's pretty good
I've also seen uh I've also seen one
where
um somebody has to perform as a mime so
this is an auction league right this is
an auction league and so everyone in
this league gets something like you get
200 of of you know fake money so the
loser of the league in this one uh
doesn't get the 200 and so he has to go
on a street corn and perform as a mine
and beg for money beg for money can't
say why he's doing can't say I'm you
know I'm last place in a fantasy league
which has to just beg for money and
can't leave until he's raised 200 in
tips
I love it uh all right give us the do's
and don'ts give us the biggest mistake
people make in fantasy
drafting-wise the biggest the biggest
mistake and this is going to sound super
obvious is they don't do enough research
uh just understanding what their league
is what are your rules what are your um
what your scoring system where are you
playing and by that I mean so people
like hey I know my league I'm like no no
like do you do you play three wide
receivers or two wide receivers you know
you're playing is it a superflex are you
in one quarterback league is it how how
big is your bench if you have a if you
have a seven person bench then you can
take some shots on some injury prone
players that high risk High reward and
if you have like two IR spots but if you
have like a three or four man bench and
no IR spots like you need like kind of
higher floor players safer players
um understanding where you play
important right if you play on ESPN
versus Yahoo like the the ADP average
draft position on those sites are very
different so understanding like going to
the site that you're going to play
whether it's one of those or you know
sleeper or CBS or NFL wherever you end
up playing is
um uh understanding where players are
going on that site because often the
average job position or the default
rankings on that site greatly influence
where people get drafted so people are
you know they've got a minute on their
clock and they're looking around like oh
and just you know the first three names
that are there they'll pick one of those
so
taking whatever set of rankings
hopefully you you like mine at you know
rotoworld.com nbcsports.com I'll get a
plug in uh like but take whatever
rankings you trust bring that in and
ideally look at the ADP of that site and
you can sort of Arbitrage say oh this
guy that I like he's going two rounds
later than I think he should so okay I
can wait a little bit on him or that's
somebody I'm going to need to reach for
because sometimes you get emotion there
or you can't draft somebody on a team
that you hate or you just don't like
that player even though that's the right
player to take for you so you go against
conventional wisdom but that's okay like
I I get I get that question all the time
like somebody asked me literally last
night he said uh he goes listen I got
pick nine
but I love Bijan Robinson this year
right oh I'm sorry he said I have pick
three you have you have Bijon at nine I
picked three yeah Bijan at nine I love
Bijan is that too early to take Bijan
Robinson I'm like no listen I have it
nine for a reason like I think he's
gonna be very good but um but no man
like you're not losing your league
because you took Bijan Robinson a three
like it's a game we play for fun and
rankings are a loose guideline of market
value that's really what they are and so
like you're not getting him back again
like if you pick three and you draft you
pass on him he's not coming back around
you so draft Bijon Robinson man you want
to root for Bichon but our running backs
how valued are they in fantasy as
opposed to real life they're more valued
in in uh in fantasy than they are in
real life I mean we're seeing this play
out in the NFL right in terms of like
you know uh Josh Jacobs just got a deal
Sake One a little while just got a deal
Jonathan Taylor that saga continues to
to go on we know Austin Eckler isn't 100
thrilled with his situation etc etc so
in in in fantasy they're they're very
valuable I will say this year more than
other years we have seen kind of a
depression of of running backs the first
round is generally mostly wide receivers
there's a couple of running backs that
are going in the first round Christian
McCaffrey Austin Eckler Bijon Robinson
Travis Kelsey goes in the first round
but the rest are generally wide
receivers because wide receivers are
hurt less they have a higher floor it's
a more of a it's more of a passing
league and I think because there's a lot
of uncertainty in some backfields people
are waiting on on running backs but I
just think as you approach your draft
actually this is a great year to wait on
running back somewhat because there's a
lot of guys going in the fourth fifth
sixth round running backs that that I
call sort of cheap volume right fantasy
success comes very from very simply two
things uh volume uh opportunity and
talent and opportunity is really volume
for running backs and so there's guys
like Damien Pierce on the Texans cam
makers on the Rams
um uh Rasheed uh Rasheed white on the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers right there's these
guys Isaiah Pacheco I think on the
Chiefs Brian Robinson on the commanders
there are guys that are going like in
those middle rounds that James Connor
and the Cardinals you're like oh well
that's not a good team you know like
they're still going to touch the ball 20
times a game uh six of the top 11
running backs last year actually played
on teams that had a losing record in the
NFL
so I just I mean like Damian Pearson who
would you take Damian Pierce is going to
have a monster year baby Paris is gonna
have a monster year who would you take
number one Justin Jefferson okay not
even close
I mean it's it's close like listen if I
if I was in a draft with you and you
took Jamar Chase one you took Chris
McCaffrey one I'm not going like what
was Dan thinking there but Justin
Jefferson I think has the highest he's
the most Talent the the most opportunity
right he's gonna get a massive amount of
targets and a passing first offense
there in uh in Minnesota cousins is a
good quarterback can get Jefferson the
ball like I just think he is he's the
greatest
um uh combination of talent and
opportunity I always say this Justin
Jefferson doesn't need to finish as the
number one wide receiver in fantasy to
be worth the number one pick
he the idea there is not that you're
trying to win your league in the first
round you're just trying not to lose it
right and so I always talk about range
of outcomes the range of outcomes for
Justin Jefferson barring injury is he's
a top five wide receiver this year like
there's no scenario where Justin
Jefferson just falls off a cliff unless
he gets hurt right and you can you can
predict that but if Kirk Cousins gets
hurt then he could fall off I suppose so
Kirk Cousins is a pretty durable
quarterback I don't think he's really
missed any time in his NFL career off
the top of my head and um I don't know I
I feel like Justin Jefferson sort of
quarterback proof like we've seen some
you know there are guys that are sort of
quarterback proof and like they're going
to scheme them open like I don't know uh
the best quarterback like is that
obvious that it's Patrick Mahomes I have
Jalen hurts at one for Fantasy so I have
Jalen I have them all right next to each
other but it's Jalen hurts Josh Allen I
have my Homes at three actually the the
idea is so four of the top six fantasy
quarterbacks last year had at least 700
yards rushing
and that in essence what you need to be
an elite fantasy quarterback these days
is you need either dual threat ability
which is you're going to get fantasy
points with your arm or and your legs
like Jalen hurts like Josh Allen or you
have 35 to 40 passing touchdown upside
like Patrick Mahomes like Joe burrow
like Justin Herbert uh I have Lamar
Jackson at four I have Herbert at five I
have Borough at six but they're all like
right there they're all Elite guys and I
think this year you want one of the top
eight quarterbacks if you can do it so
those are my top six I have fields at
seven again with a rushing and then I
have Trevor Lauren today I think Trevor
Lawrence takes a big step this year yeah
I do too I think he might be uh you know
up there knocking on the door of a top
five quarterback who have you heard from
celebrity wise to who have asked for
some advice
uh it's it's a it's a pretty long list
uh it's a pretty long list candidly um
I've told this story before but the my
favorite story is is that about 10 years
ago I get a call from a guy who says Hey
Matthew you're um uh we're big fans of
you can come by our league you know and
you know it's August 28th in New York
and we'd love to have you you know come
just sort of grade the picks hang out
and I'm like I don't I don't really go
to random people's drafts in New York's
like two hours away from me could I send
a video for your league like I'm
appreciative but I gotta pass and he
goes well it's it's for Jay-Z's League
what what time do you need me
what time do you need me did you go to
the 40 40 class oh yes so it's in a
private room at the 4040 club and the
the end of that story is again I've told
this before but the the end of that
story is so I walk in and I'm a surprise
for him so the the person who invited me
is Mike Kaiser um who's the president of
Atlantic Records and so uh Kaiser
invites me there and I walk in I walk
into the room and I get recognized and
all of a sudden so so Jay looks at me
and is just like you know Barry get over
here and all of a sudden
um uh this other guy says what no Barry
you sit the hell down you don't he's
using strong language than that but he's
just like no Barry you don't move what's
going on Hove you know you don't bring
Jordan to a pickup game you don't bring
Jordan to a pickup game and so now
they're yelling back and forth and
they're like and and Jay is like shut up
Irv Barry get over here and turns out
the the guy that was yelling is Irv
Gotti a Murder Inc Irv Gotti like the
legend Irv Gotti I don't I know the name
but I don't recognize him I just think
it's this loud guy named curve and so
they're going back and forth those two
right they're um you know Jay's like
Barry get over here and Herb's like
Barry don't you move you get the hell
out of here and so they're yelling and
um and everyone in in the in the room is
having fun and going back and forth and
eventually like I sort of I'm starting
feeling my oats you know I'm feeling
comfortable and everyone's having fun so
I'm like yeah Irv shut up and sit down
room goes silent and I'm like oh God oh
God what did I just do room goes silent
and it's it's probably like 20 seconds
but for me it feels like two minutes
and like the room like you could hear
pin drop and then eventually like Irv
goes okay bear you're all right you're
right you can stay you can stay and so
uh ever since so uh yeah no it's
unbelievable that that league is amazing
so that's that's probably that's my
favorite uh celebrity that has reached
out he's uh Matthew Berry NBC sports
fantasy football analyst and uh you'll
be able to see him in a variety of ways
fantasy football happy hour weekdays at
noon Eastern on peacock and then every
NFL Sunday he'll host fantasy football
pregame at 11 A.M Eastern on peacock and
then you're going to be in Kansas City
for the Lions and the Chiefs September
7th it's great to see you again uh yeah
I always appreciate you uh your
contributions to the program well thank
you
here fellow peacockian right you know
we're uh you know happy to happy to do
that and uh I appreciate I saw you
backstage at uh at Darius Rucker where
uh fritzy absolutely killed it you mean
killed it in a good way or a bad way I'm
gonna tell you like I don't know how you
guys felt I had such low expectations I
had heard before the show
that he was going to sing two songs and
I'm like really yeah two songs and I he
was better than I thought he was going
to be that that was my take but
expectations you had zero so he had to
be better if he had zero X I had zero
I'm just like all right well it's like
it's it's clearly like I know Darius I'm
in a fantasy league with darius's too
and so I know like uh you know he's a
big he's a good friend of yours and a
friend of the show and and uh loves to
you know loves to play Fantasy love to
you know make a bet I'm just like well
there's no way Dan's betting him
somebody good to be on his show like I
mean you know like like if there's
somebody that can really sing Dan's not
gonna let him you know like it's not
funny if if he's really good yeah so I'm
assuming he's awful and I thought like I
thought he did what you do at karaoke
which is like pick a song you can sort
of get through without embarrassing
yourself and I thought I thought he he
exceeded that even my wife who knows
nothing about uh you know doesn't listen
to the show and but she was just like he
was pretty good so thank you very much I
appreciate that I I did did you guys
comment because I didn't hear the next
day like the only thing was like he kept
his hands in his pockets for two
straight songs yeah no Showmanship yeah
people had a problem with that
um they they were
they had some some thoughts there about
why tied out his hands in his pants
it's great to see you we'll uh we'll
take a break we'll come back phone calls
after this
[Music]